est-ce que vous êtes prêts
donc on est bien j'ai demandé aux gens
de fermer les portes donc vous allez
devoir m'écouter pendant 18 minutes
c'est limité merci bonjour à tous En
tout cas bonjour La HEC super content de
revenir dans mon école les HEC où je
suis arrivé en 1995 comme j'ai toujours
moi je suis arrivé en plein référendum
alors que pour un petit gars qui avait
fait science politique à l'époque waouh
il y avait une animation ici donc merci
c'est Amelina Bellan pour m'avoir invité
c'est super sympa ça retient ça et on y
va tout de suite mais j'ai pas mon
clicker donc j'ai pas ouvert le petit
cœur qui peut me donner
et voilà
donc le Québec ma nouvelle patrie j'ai
la chance pendant le covid coincé
pendant l'été je vais aller jusqu'au
bout de la route okaska et chez là j'ai
compris peut-être après 28 ans au Québec
la puissance du Saint-Laurent j'avais
jamais eu la chance de parcourir tout ce
Saint-Laurent jusqu'au bout et d'aller
voir les îles mains gants que je trouve
exceptionnel et j'en ai fait des îles
que j'ai fait beaucoup de voile quand
j'étais jeune en Méditerranée et Le
Havre Saint-Pierre son petit port de
pêche je me lève à l'aller et au retour
je me suis arrêté j'ai pris mon gros
homard à chaque fois et c'est fabuleux
je me dis quelque chose que c'est beau
ce Québec c'est beau aussi quand on va
chez les amis dans un chalet une soirée
s'est couché de soleil puis là je mets
toujours c'est beau c'est grand c'est
généreux ce Québec
mais ce qui m'ennuie c'est que tout ça
c'est menacé notre Québec est menacé la
planète est menacée et on le sait on
sait qu'on en fait rien ou très peu et
on doit agir et on doit agir de partout
au nouveau du gouvernement au niveau des
institutions publiques au niveau des
compagnies privées dans laquelle je suis
par exemple et toutes les autres donc
quoi faire on sait que ça va
l'alimentation la température va monter
au moins un point cinq degrés on le sait
on le sait
alors on peut faire l'autruche facile de
faire l'autruche j'en ai dans mon
entourage les gens qui font l'autruche
le chalet les deux motoneiges le machin
le truc ouais ou alors on peut penser à
notre empreinte carbone tous les jours
quand on fait une action
on peut se dédouaner en achetant un
véhicule électrique mais l'inepsie j'ai
peut-être pas me faire des amis
aujourd'hui
inepsie c'est d'acheter un camion
électrique dans ton y pense pour aller
d'un point un point B il y a pas besoin
d'un camion électrique quoi qu'il arrive
qu'il soit essentiel électrique et même
si électrique c'est mieux on s'entend il
va toujours plus consommer parce qu'il
est plus lourd il lui faudra encore plus
de puissance énergétique donc il faudra
plus exister donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
au niveau des gouvernements on est au
Canada et au Québec
on est avant contraire pour moi
même s'il y a eu un budget fédéral cette
semaine qui nous annonce un plan plus
vert malgré que dans le plan on trouve
que la captation de carbone c'est une
bonne idée alors que c'est franchement
ridicule
on va donner en tant qu'a contribuable
financer transmontaine ça coûte 30
milliards de dollars pour une pipeline
qui passe de l'Alberta jusque dans
l'Ouest pour l'exporter 300 000 barils
de pétrole salle tous les jours faut se
dire on est Canadiens il faut se le dire
on le fait et on finance avec ça puis
d'un autre côté on se pose des questions
et sur le Québec si on devrait pas
rajouter un demi Hydro-Québec pour
décarboner le Québec c'est pas vrai
parce qu'on a encore beaucoup de carbone
on véhicule beaucoup en transport quand
une Mélina m'a demandé ce que tu viens
en voiture je peux pas venir en voiture
je sais c'est pas dans ma profession de
soi j'habite Montréal je suis en vélo où
je suis en métro bon bah il faut
décarboner le Québec et ça on peut le
faire avec Hydro-Québec si on va de
l'avant avec des projets demain
donc ça c'est ça c'est les gouvernements
c'est facile de critiquer vraiment moi
le premier est facile on se dédouane on
vote puis après il se débrouille moi je
suis en business
j'arrive peut-être un certain âge
peut-être de sage je me dis ok qu'est-ce
que je fais dans les 15 prochaines
années pour vraiment changer les choses
et quand je dis des rapports comme
United nation qui me dit
one and the private
moi ça m'interpelle je suis sûr que ça
vous interpelle qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire dans nos propres business même il
y a aussi beaucoup d'étudiants ici
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans notre
propre études pour s'assurer qu'on va en
avant et qu'on va décarboner la planète
dans les prochaines années et c'est pas
dans cet an dans 15 ans c'est maintenant
que ça se passe donc on réfléchit et
qu'est-ce qu'on réfléchit c'est que on
faut une transition qui est maintenant
je pose de la chance de dire leur varie
d'elle qui est la cofondatrice des
critères qui est honnêtement une femme
exceptionnelle qui a créé aussi mère au
front j'essaie de les aider que quand on
a un peu de temps pour leur site web
mais refont qui fait la pression sur le
moment fédéral pour avoir une loi dans
la Constitution pour obliger et forcer
le Canada respecter ces engagements au
niveau climatique et il faut le forcer
dans la Constitution il faut que ce soit
inscrit dans la constitution même si je
sais qu'on veut pas réouvrir
le dossier constitutionnel au Canada et
au Québec j'ai même appelé un grand
professeur constitutionnel récemment non
mais il faut le faire pourquoi on le
fait pas immédiatement c'est compliqué à
la Constitution mais c'est pas grave il
faut l'inscrire dans cette Constitution
il faut qu'on change qu'on force le
Canada respecter ses engagements
climatiques donc je vous invite à lire
son livre l'heure elle est super elle
vous donne juste des petits conseils
pour changer quelques habitudes et même
elle dit une sonde
c'était une autruche
elle le dit il y avait un gros chat puis
maintenant il a changé donc on peut tout
changer oui exactement
donc je sais donc je suis non je sais
dans le Jaggi on doit agir nous tous
quand on vote quand on achète un produit
quand vous achetez un produit d'une
compagnie et cette vérifier si cette
compagnie là et dans la transition va
dans la transition on le sait parfois il
y en a qui le font pas on sait qu'il y
en a qui font du greenwashing incroyable
mais regardez vous achetez quand vous
prenez un cours au HC peut-être vous
voulez prendre une thématique
environnementaliste intéressant je vais
prendre tel sujet et peut-être à la fin
de ma conversation vous allez peut-être
prendre eh moi je vais prendre 10 jours
donc on doit agir et moi dans notre
compagnie c'est d'amener aussi nos
compagnies à changer alors les
compagnies changent évoluent elles font
déjà par une première chose
c'est le net 0 carbone moi j'appelle ça
chez nous on appelle ça le net des
requins qu'est-ce que c'est c'est que on
s'est défini sur un 2030 2035 2040 2050
c'est pas grave chacun ses objectifs
c'est plus ou moins compliqué d'aller
obser son carbone dans une compagnie
mais on a décidé de réduire de
restrictement notre empreinte carbone
dans les compagnies à 90% puis le 10
derniers pour cent de carbone que vous
allez produire vous allez acheter des
carbone parce que vous parce qu'on peut
pas réduire complètement l'empreinte
carbone d'une compagnie ça serait
impossible mais donc les compagnies de
travail pour ça
c'est super facile ça veut dire quoi par
concrètement je vous donne un exemple
nous par exemple on a notre empreinte
carbone avec le bureau de Montréal j'ai
déjà de l'énergie renouvelable dans mes
bureaux vous pouvez tous imaginer que on
était 350 personnes avant le covid j'ai
beaucoup trop de pieds carrés en ce
moment
parce que j'ai plus personne qui vient
au bureau puisqu'on a décidé de rester
complètement ouvert sans forcer les gens
revenir au bureau ce fait que je me
retrouve dans une négociation vous
pouvez imaginer dans quelques mois où je
vais vouloir
donc je vais négocier pour diminuer mes
bureaux ceci étant dit je peux déjà vous
dire que je ne reprendrai pas des
bureaux demain dans une nouvelle
négociation où il y aurait pas de
l'énergie renouvelable parce que mon
empreinte carbone aujourd'hui il est de
X et le chauffage est hyper important
donc déjà on prend ces critères là
quand on quand on regarde pour les
bureaux quand on fait une acquisition on
a fait 5 acquisitions l'an dernier dans
une boîte à Montréal c'est pas encore
dans les équipes de M&M's mais
tranquillement pas vite on pousse en
disant mais moi faut que je regarde en
plein carbone parce que si demain on
achète une compagnie que Texas dont 100%
des employés viennent en voiture on va
faire exploser notre empreinte carbone
donc on commence à amener ces critères
là tranquillement
et le Québec a une chance inouï puisque
majoritairement à 60% de son grille
d'électricité de consommation on a les
droits donc
il y a beaucoup de greenwashing alors
moi j'ai la chance de travailler dans
une sociabilité donc quand je rencontre
des clients on dit toujours je me dis
tiens je vais regarder c'est la fin qui
fait du greenwashing d'accord ouais ils
vont faire des efforts au niveau de zéro
carbone à plein de projet Damien je
t'appelle je vais réduire absolument ma
production de d'énergie au niveau de mes
centres mes serveurs et tout ça j'arrive
souvent dans une salle d'attente et je
me dis tiens j'ai peur le test de Damien
c'est ultra simple vous arrivez dans une
compagnie vous avez regardé s'ils ont
ambition ils en ont parfait ils en ont
pas ils en ont par exemple et là vous
demandez de l'eau parce que j'attends la
personne qui doit me recevoir et c'est
très simple
soit je reçois un verre d'eau dans un
verre normal et je me dis des works de
toc ou soit je reçois une bouteille
d'eau en plastique et ça ça me fout en
rage et je me dis ça arrive encore une
fois sur 10 comme il y avait des vers en
plastique ce matin et je vous l'ai dit
je vous l'ai dit je vais faire attention
à ça je vous embête tous avec ça mais
c'est super attention c'est tellement
simple de mettre des verres normales il
y a pas de les mettre dans la vaisselle
c'est pas si compliqué que ça donc ça
c'est le deuxième meilleur retenez-le
pour le kenwashing c'est ça marche à
tous les coups vous voyez ce coup de
l'ambition qui est des work de top puis
ceux qui en ont ceux qui en ont mais ils
sont peut-être pas aussi verts on peut
le penser donc maintenant je vais vous
parler des écosystèmes numériques parce
que moi
je travaille dans une industrie
aujourd'hui qui on pense relativement
propre et bien c'est faux l'industrie
dans laquelle je travaille et j'ai pas
de problème à vous le dire
et extrêmement polluante
on pense système numérique c'est
polluant pourquoi d'abord on est quatre
points 7 milliards à jouer dans la
planète tous les jours 30 milliards
devices connectées tous les jours dans
vos maisons aujourd'hui quand j'ai fait
une conférence il y a une dizaine
d'années j'avais dit vous verrez vous
avez au moins 10 15 objets connectés
chez vous c'est même pas 10-15 objets
connectés vous avez chez vous
aujourd'hui entre la puce pour le chat
pour qu'il puisse rentrer à l'extérieur
de la maison à la voiture qui est
connectée directement chez vous vous
appelez téléphoniques etc le Nest pour
votre chauffage vous avez facilement 15
20 225 appareils qui sont connectés chez
vous qui se connecte chez vous d'accord
c'est 4% de la consommation d'énergie
aujourd'hui le numérique vous allez me
dire rien là
c'est 4% de l'empreintes carbone mais
mon problème c'est qu'en 2030 c'est 20%
de la consommation d'énergie
alors c'est vrai que c'est comme mieux
comme je faisais dans le passé je le
reconnais j'allais souvent à New York
dans la journée pour faire une
conférence d'une heure et aujourd'hui je
vais regarder je vais me faire ça en
zoom ou en teams et mon empreinte
carbone a fortement lui elle existe
encore mais elle est quand même
nettement meilleure que quand j'allais
prendre un avion pour la journée pour la
New York par exemple
mais ça reste que c'est un enjeu
considérable donc il faut qu'on réduise
l'empreinte carbone du numérique
donc comment faire mais après c'est de
se dire bah déjà c'est de comprendre que
déchets numériques qui gagnent déchets
physiques quand vous streamez chez vous
le soir dites vous pas c'est virtuel je
consomme rien il y a pas de souci il y a
énormément de d'énergie consommée si les
serveurs de la série que vous regardez
sont Texas il y a une forte probabilité
que c'est l'énergie non renouvelable qui
est utilisée pour pousser votre film sur
le serveur au Texas et puis après quand
votre film arrive chez vous sur votre
device qui soit dans votre appareil de
téléphone s'il est ou votre ordinateur
il y a de l'énergie encore qu'à utiliser
donc l'énergie des serveurs à la base où
sont les serveurs énergies pour
l'appareil de l'usager d'accord et ça on
peut travailler là-dessus et la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on peut travailler
là-dessus mais déjà il faut prendre en
considération que c'est des déchets
physiques
donc comment on fait reste à nous de
jouer alors je vais pas vous parler des
anges de tout ce que pourrait faire pour
diminuer votre consommation numérique
déjà soyez au courant que effectivement
quand vous utilisez le numérique on
consomme quand on fait du Tik Tok là
pendant deux heures avant de se coucher
on consomme peut-être qu'on pourrait
faire autre chose par exemple
écoutez moi YouTube si vous discutez la
musique peut-être c'est mieux d'utiliser
Spotify pour écouter la musique il y a
pas de vidéo mais si vous regardez le
vidéo il y a pas de problème mais si
vous laissez juste votre ordinateur
jouer du YouTube et vous écoutez la
musique peut-être c'est pas une bonne
discipline une bonne pratique par
exemple de votre côté mais moi de mon
côté je peux extrêmement agir pour
diminuer leur point de carbone je vais
vous montrer comment
on appelle ça l'echo-conception donc
l'éco-conception ça me permet de
concevoir des moi j'appelle ça des sites
web tout ce que je fais des actifs
numériques donc ces actifs numériques là
je vais être en mesure de diminuer
l'empreinte carbone de ses actifs là où
je vais même optimiser ses actifs là
donc je suis souvent appelé je travaille
en ce moment avec un groupe en Suisse
grosse compagnie dans le monde
d'affinance qui me dit ok tu regardes
tous mes serveurs tu me dis quoi faire
et puis donc je vais regarder à la fois
les sites web mais l'empreinte carbone
d'un site web et X ou Y je vais regarder
tout ce qui data parce qu'il y a
énormément de données de Data leg à data
leg très gros qui est sur le cœur sur
les surveurs de mon client en Suisse qui
consomme énormément d'énergie donc on va
regarder qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec
ça donc je vais regarder l'ensemble des
du numérique chez un client puis je vais
essayer de diminuer l'empreinte carbone
de ce client là donc comment on le fait
on peut le d'abord la bonne nouvelle
c'est que on peut le faire c'est que on
peut réduire l'empreinte carbone c'est
super et on peut le faire dès maintenant
donc on a aucun aucune raison
aujourd'hui pour ne pas le faire on peut
le faire comment on le fait
il y a quatre axes pour le faire il y a
les centres de données dont je vais vous
parler vous allez voir et après tout ce
qui est réseau l'optimisation des
réseaux je vous en parlerai pas
aujourd'hui c'est trop compliqué mais il
y a les appareils de l'appareil de
l'usager je vous en ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais on va vous montrer quelques
exemples et puis la production de
matériel d'accord donc les centres de
données par exemple c'est ou même un
fichier c'est aussi simple que de
réduire un fichier un petit fichier qui
traîne quelque part on en fait plein
avec mes programmes il y a plein de
fichiers qui traînent quelque part
honnêtement on n'est pas très bon là
c'est comme une maison qui est un peu
sale vous savez il faut vraiment
ramasser la poussière faut faire du
clean up dès qu'on fait du clean up on
peut descendre dans le coin de carbone
d'un site web de 10 ou 15% hyper
facilement parce que il y a plein de
lignes de codes qui traînent etc etc
donc aujourd'hui on essaie vraiment
d'être très rigoureux donc comment le
faire par exemple c'est aussi simple que
Dannick van Cotten le test de Danny van
Cotten c'est un gars qui crée des
plugins sur WordPress donc je sais pas
si vous connaissez WordPress mais 30%
des sites Web dans le monde aujourd'hui
c'est ce WordPress donc c'est énorme
presse d'accord et lui créer ses plugins
là et il a un jour créé un plugin qui
est sur deux millions
de d'instance numérique puis là il se
dit mon plugin est sur 2 millions
d'instances numériques je vais juste le
réduire de 1 kg qui est dans notre monde
à nous rien d'accord c'est comme enlever
10 kg sur une voiture qui fait 600 kg
c'est rien
il enlève ce qu'il a optait comme c'est
répliqué sur 2 millions de sites web
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il a réduit l'empreinte carbone de 3
tonnes par mois 3 tonnes pas moins x 12
ça fait 36 à 36 tonnes de carbone en
moins sur l'année juste ça ou c'est
l'équivalent par mois de 5 passagers qui
prennent un vol New York Amsterdam voilà
juste en faisant ça
c'est rien c'est c'est une poussière
dans notre monde cotton donc on peut
faire ça c'est aussi simple que
d'identifier les fuites carbone donc je
reviens sur mon exemple de tout à
l'heure vous allez voir ici bingo j'ai
toutes les instances sur un serveur de
mon client et là je vois quatre on
appelle ça des carbone link lix pour
nous en fait là j'y tiens la 4 qui
consomme énormément d'énergie on va
forcément notre première chose qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va regarder en
l'occurrence je vous dis qu'il y a un
datalik il y a un site marketing de
communication avec une tonne de vidéos
ça c'est catastrophique donc après c'est
de regarder moi je me suis pas fait
d'amis j'ai supprimé la vidéo qui était
sur le site de Valtech je vous cache pas
que le siemo il me va encore quand je le
croise quand je vais à Paris
je le trouve c'est lui qui m'a supprimé
ma belle vidéo j'ai investi je sais pas
combien d'argent pour la vidéo on
supprime la vidéo du site web ça
consomme 20% de l'empreinte carbone de
notre site
donc on l'a supprimé donc on regarde et
les deux les deux derniers ici sont plus
par rapport à du Data transfert sur des
applications bien spécifiques et donc on
regarde ça et puis on intervient et on
va donc être capable de réduire
l'empreinte carbone des sites en
l'occurrence de ce client là
vous avez Google qui vous donne votre
empreinte carbone quand vous allez sur
les serveurs il vous donne votre
empreinte carbone
c'est super vous êtes capable avec
Google aussi de choisir la région vous
voulez vos serveurs si vous voulez
vraiment des serveurs propres vous le
dites vous poussez le slider sur la
droite le carbone print et il va vous
trouver et il va vous mettre sur des
serveurs propres
le monde a réduit son impact de 21% dans
quelques actions
il y a toute une méthodologie qui est
mise en place on prend les parcours
clients et on va identifier l'empreinte
carbone d'un site web donc on d'abord
pour partir un projet de carbone comme
ça c'est de faire une audit de carbone
identifiée son empreinte carbone
et on vise en gros un gramme par page si
vous êtes au-dessus d'un gramme par page
si vous pouvez vraiment travailler si
vous êtes déjà sur la moyenne d'un
gramme par page c'est pas mal mais on
peut faire nettement mieux on a 0.7 en
ce moment par exemple on peut diminuer
mais déjà vous êtes un gramme c'est bien
il y a une tonne d'outils qui nous
permet de mesurer conclusion
on peut le faire et on doit le faire
j'en appelle à tous ceux qui sont
donneur d'ordre de projet dans le
numérique faites votre carbone
donnez-vous un objectif carbone pour la
prochaine création d'un actif numérique
site web ou autre on peut le faire merci
beaucoup et comment on dit au Québec à
la prochaine fois
[Applaudissements]